- [grunts]
- [shushing]
Showtime.
- Yeah.
- Sit tight, you bizznatch.
- Hello, TelAmericorp
and any other offices out there
that can hear us.
We are Menergy.
- Let's get menergized!
- Whoo!
[New wave music]
- ♪ When you need me,
I'll be there ♪
♪ 'Cause we're best friends ♪
- ♪ When you see me,
there's no fear ♪
♪ 'Cause we're best friends ♪
both: ♪ Do you trust me
like I trust you? ♪
♪ I don't care who overhears
our conversation ♪
[music stops]
[both stammer]
[recording]
- He doesn't understand.
I'm the brains of the operation.
- Wait, what?
[recording]
There is no band
without me, Adam.
- What the hell is that?
What are you saying?
- You just said something first.
[recording]
- He's just a diva.
- I'm the diva?
Look how hard your hair is
right now.
I'm the diva?
- Hey, I wake up like this.
You want to get real?
We both know Menergy
wouldn't exist
without me, the brains.
- Okay, I'm the talent
of the operation.
- I thought
you guys were friends.
Like how every line of your song
is about being friends?
- Yeah, we're friends, Bill.
- We're friends, okay?
- This is a spat
between friends.
[recording]
Kind of like the band Everclear.
I'm Art Alexakis.
He's Craig Montoya
and Greg Eklund.
- Okay, let me be
ever so clear about this.
You are no Art Alexakis.
- I'm totally Art Alexakis,
and I told Blake that--okay.
- [clapping]